HOI LAM: Android Wear 2.0 is
the most significant update
to Android Wear since
its launch in 2014.
I'm Hoi Lam, and
I'm here to take you
through three highlights
of Android Wear 2.0.
First, Material Design has
arrived on Android Wear.
The new Android Wear interface
uses a darker color palette,
which makes the watch blend in
more in social environments.
It also helps save battery
by [INAUDIBLE] displays.
We also suggest that
developer adopts
vertical layouts and
reserve horizontal
swipe for activity dismissal.
In our research, this makes
the user interface easier
to understand.
To help develop and implement
these new design patterns,
we have introduced new
user interface components,
such as the wearable
[? draw layout ?]
and wearable recycler view.
Check out the Material
Design for Android Wear site
for more details.
The second highlights
for Android Wear 2.0
is watch face complications.
Before Android Wear
2.0, if a watch face
wanted to display
data from another app,
they need a one-to-one agreement
in both business and technical
terms.
To alleviate this complexity
with Android Wear 2.0,
we have introduced
a complications API.
Complications are a
traditional watchmaking term
for areas of the watch face
that displays information
other than the time, such as
the date or phases of the moon.
We have extended this
concept to smartwatches,
so any app can publish data
for watch faces to consume.
And watch faces can
display this data
in a style that fits into
their unique designs.
For app developers,
this helps increase user
engagement and mindshare.
For watch face makers, this
adds utility to the watch face.
Users can now choose whichever
watch face they want,
as well as getting the
data that they need.
Check out the Watch
Face and Complications
sections of the Developer
Documentation for more details.
Last but not least,
standalone functionality--
previously, Android
Wear 1.0 apps
require a phone app to
communicate with the cloud.
With Android Wear 2.0, wear
apps can access the internet
directly without the need for
a corresponding Android phone
app installed.
This means the Android Wear
app can access the internet,
even if the user has an iPhone.
To help with app
distribution, we
have also put the Google
Play Store on the watch.
Users can now download apps
directly on their wrists.
Apart from these three
areas of improvement--
Material Design, complications,
and standalone apps--
there are numerous
other enhancements
with Android Wear 2.0.
Check out the Android
Wear Developer
site for more details.
I'm Hoi Lam.
Happy coding.
Thank you for watching.
We have also got a series
on Android Wear performance.
Check out all these
videos to find out more.